翻訳: Shuta Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は 約30年にわたって
経営コンサルタントあるいは
企業アドバイザーの仕事をしてきました
30年ということですから
ちょうど最初の15年は 20世紀
後半の15年は まさに
21世紀ということなんですけども
今日話したいテーマ 重要なことは
この20世紀の後半
そしてこの21世紀の前半にかけて
大きな変化が起きた
その変化に対して
特に私の専門は企業なんですが
企業の組織 あるいは個人というのは
なぜ簡単に対応することができないのか
なぜ変化は難しいのかということで
チェンジ 変化をテーマに
少しお話をしたいという風に思います
最初に 今起きたその世界の経済構造
あるいは社会の構造
結果として 企業の経営環境が
どう変化したのか
何が変化したのかということを
少しお話をしたいという風に思います
３つ書いてあります
１個目 グローバライゼーション
２個目 マーケタイゼーション
３個目 デジタライゼーション
重要なことは
この後ご説明しますけども
この３つの大きな変化というのが
同時並行的にほぼ20世紀の最後
それこそ85年以降起きたということです
これが複合し 合わさったことによって
非常に巨大な変革が
今進行しているということです
まず１点目の
グローバライゼーションですけども
象徴的にはこれは1989年の確か11月9日
ベルリンの壁の崩壊というのがありました
その結果 ー
戦後長く 日本を含む日米欧
先進国５億人の経済クラブ
この安定した先進国経済というのが
まさにグローバル経済
ほとんど全てだったわけです —
そこに一気に20億 そして40億という
新たな市場が加わった
その市場っていうのは
均質な市場ではなくて
非常に変化の激しい
ダイナミックな市場が誕生した
また新たな競合プレイヤーも台頭した
当然 企業の戦略
そして企業の組織というのも
劇的な変化というのが要求されたわけです
それから２番目の
マーケタイゼーションというのは
要は資本市場の拡大です
これも急膨張しました
今や１日の
例えば為替取引額というのは
多い時には５兆ドル
すなわち 600兆円
これは日本が１年間に活動した
成果としてのGDPを
超える数字が １日で取引されている
ここまで市場が巨大化したということです
したがってかつては金融というのは
経済 あるいは実体経済を支える
血流であるとか インフラの
役割だったわけです
ところが今や
金融経済が変動すると
実体経済が振り回される
すなわち 犬で言えば
尻尾が胴体を振り回すような
状況になってしまった
経営という観点からいけば
結局 金融の危機が
実体経済の危機に波及する
我々は最近リーマンショックというのを
経験したばかりですけれども
そうするとこれだけ変動がある
危機が頻発する経済 あるいは市場に
どう対応するかということが
大きなテーマになってきます
それから市場という意味においては
特に企業にとってみると
ここ10年 15年で重要になったのは
やはり株式市場
株式市場の影響が非常に高まった
あるいは株主価値経営というのが
浸透してきたということです
私が駆け出しのコンサルタントだった頃
それこそ80年代の後半とか90年
株価を気にしてるとか
株主価値経営を標榜しているような
経営者というのはほとんどいませんでした
今「株主なんか関係ない」という発言を
上場企業のトップがしたら
大変なペナルティーを
マーケットから受けるということで
こうした株式価値経営というものが
浸透してきたのも
この10年 15年
それからもう１つ
資本市場のインパクトで大きいのは
結局 市場において
企業の値段がつく
事業の値段がつく
その結果M&A
要するに事業や企業の売買ということが
盛んに活発になったわけです
これもかつては
少なくとも日本においては
非常套的な手段であったものが
今日これはもう常套手段であり
これを否定する経営者もいなくなった
当然それは企業の経営のあり方
そして経営能力においても
新たなチャレンジを突きつけたことも
言うまでもありません
それから３つ目が
デジタライゼーションで
これは説明する必要もないと思います
例えば パソコンが生まれたのは
80年代の半ば
Macintoshが出たのは 84年
MicrosoftがWindowsを出したのは85年
90年代になると
インターネットが台頭してきます
Netscapeが生まれたのは 95年
Googleが誕生したのは 1998年
そうして2000年以降
IMT-2000と言われるくらいですから
３Gのネットワーク
ワイヤレスの世界が入ってきたのが
2000年以降
そしてソーシャルということで
Facebookが創業したのが 2004年
85年から今日まで
この圧縮された期間の中において
デジタライゼーション
インターネットや
それからITの技術の革新というのは
劇的に進んだわけです
これも言うまでもなく
企業経営のあり方や 企業の組織のあり方
ビジネスモデルに
大きな変革を迫ったわけです
これだけ環境が変わったわけですから
企業もそして我々個人も
変化をしなければいけないわけですけども
実際にはなかなか変革することが難しい
企業の場合 組織の場合
変革できずに競争力を失っていく
こういうケースも多いわけです
なぜ組織の変革が難しいのか
まず１点目 ブレインストップ
すなわち思考停止
つまり変化に気付くことがない
あるいは場合によっては
変化を無視してしまう
こういうことが
特に組織においては起き得ます
典型的なパターンを言うと
成功体験
これは誰しもそうですが
成功すればその成功を守りたくなる
企業においてもそうです
成功してる事業があれば
それにチャレンジしてくるもの
それに挑戦してくるものというのは
できれば排除をしたいし
過小評価をすることもよくあります
例えば思い出すのは80年代
日本の自動車会社のトップは
韓国の自動車産業が
日本の自動車産業に
キャッチアップすることは
ないだろうと言っていました
あるいは90年代に
通信会社のトップが
インターネットが実用に至る
ということはないだろうと
こういう発言もしていました
この様にやはり過小評価をする傾向
というのはあるわけです
ここに組織が関与すると
問題が深刻化します
例えば 当然
成功している事業のトップというのは
その会社の中で取り立たてられて
全社のトップ
影響力のあるポジションに就くわけです
そうするとその人の
価値観 成功体験というのが
その組織を支配するようになる
それがもしサラリーマン型の組織
官僚型の組織だとすると
誰もその人に 上位者に
チャレンジする人がいない
チャレンジしても報われないから
そうすると実は外で
変化に気が付いていたとしても
それは意思決定者へ届かない
結局組織的に内向きになり
思考停止になる
こういう状況 こういうことに
私は 多く遭遇しました
１個目が 気付かないブレインストップ
２個目が パスディペンデンスと
書いてありますけれども
直訳をすれば 「経路依存性」
これは人も組織も同じですけれども
自分が学んだこと
身につけた知識・技術で問題を解決する
当然そういうことになるわけです
ところが企業の場合は
それが問題になるわけです
こういう諺があります
「あなたが持っている道具が金槌だとすると
全ての問題は釘に見える」
すなわち メカトロに長けていれば
やっぱりメカトロで解決しようとする
ハードに長けていれば
ハードの技術で解決をしようとする
ところが例えば
AppleがiTunesとiPodで
新しい音楽のサービスの
提供に出てきたときに
そうしたメカトロやハードに長けた
日本の電機メーカーというのは
ほとんど対応することができなかった
これはパスディペンデンス
要はスキルの欠落
こういう問題というのが
やっぱり変化に
気付いたとしてもできないという
こういう問題に遭遇するわけです
３番目に書いてあるのが
コンプレキシティ
言ってみれば「しがらみ」です
特に成功している事業であればあるほど
そこにおいては
利益共同体的な性格を帯びます
それは川上のサプライヤーから
川下の流通 販売まで含めて
利益共同体になってくる
そうすると自社が
大きくビジネスモデルを転換したい
でもそれは 川上や川下の
人たちにとってみると
収益を失ってしまうということに
なるかもしれない
当然抵抗をする
あるいはこちら側も配慮をする
結果的に調整コスト
調整の時間が膨大になって
変化ができない
気付いてスキルがあったとしても
変化に手間取る
こういうことになります
業務も同様で
成功している業務であればあるほど
そこにおいては
作り込まれたプロセスがある
そこに新しい技術が出てきたとしても
その技術を自分だけが取り入れた場合
全体最適が崩れてしまう
これがコンプレキシティの罠なわけです
こうした
ブレインストップ、パスディペンデンス
コンプレキシティというのは
どの組織でも起き得るわけで
変化に気が付かない
気付いたとしても その能力がない
能力があったとしても 変わらない
色んな罠が 色々あるということです
じゃあどうすればいいのか
ということなんですけども
いわゆるコインの裏返し
簡単な答えを言えば
ブレインストップを排除するためには
常に考える組織を作ればいいと
具体的にはよく言われる
開かれた組織 オープンな組織
外との交流がある組織
そしてより重要なことは
社内の体質として チャレンジする
そうした体質というのを
社内に作っていくと
ジョブズがAppleの企業体質を
説明するときに
Appleでは
「（英語）一番いいアイデアが勝つべきだ」
と言っています
誰が言ったかとか
上位者が言ったかじゃなくて
一番いいアイデアを出したやつ
そのアイデアを取っていくという
こういう体質を作ったと
それがAppleの強さだという風に
ジョブズは言っています
こうした組織
こうしたものを作れるか
こうした風土
それが大きなテーマになります
それから パスディペンデンスを
克服するためには
それは文字通り
新しいスキルを学習すればいい
あるいは古いスキルを
アンラーニングすればいい
しかしこれは実際にはなかなか難しい
経営という立場でいけば
人を入れ替える 事業を入れ替える
こういうことをする
ということになるわけですけれども
大変に厳しい判断が求められる
それからコンプレキシティ
しがらみを突破するというのは
これはもう そうした
利害関係者というのも巻き込んで
強い意志を持って
改革を進めていくしかないわけです
じゃあこれは誰がやるのかと
いうことになれば
言うまでもなく リーダーシップ
リーダーの仕事だ
ということになるわけです
変革を示し そして変革を進めていくのは
リーダーの仕事になるわけですが
今日リーダーシップぐらい
稀少な資源はない
求められる資源はない
人材はないと
それはもう企業の現場においても
教育の現場においても
リーダー育成というのが
最大のテーマになっている
なぜか？
それは変革の時代だからです
じゃあリーダーシップやリーダーの
対語は何かと言えば
あえて言えばマネージャーあるいは
マネージメントということになります
ここで言うマネージャーというのは
決められた枠組みの中において
きちんと成果を出す
大変に重要な役割です
ただ 今申し上げたように
変化の時代においては
この枠組みを壊していく
こういう力が必要であって
それはマネージャーの仕事ではなく
リーダーの仕事になるということです
今日は TEDxUTokyoということで
東大に来ています
東京大学というのは 紛れもなく
あらゆる指標を取っても
日本のリーディングユニバーシティ
であることは間違いないですし
アジアの
リーディングユニバーシティであり
世界有数の
リーディングユニバーシティです
じゃあリーディングユニバーシティの
東京大学が リーダーを生んでいるのか？
アカデミアの分野ではどうか？
卑近な例でいけば ノーベル賞
プレゼンス東京大学とは強いのか？
あるいはビジネスの分野で言ったら
ビジネスアントレプレナー
ビジネスリーダー
プレゼンスは高いのか？
必ずしもそうでもない
ということだと思います
考えてみれば 東京大学は
優秀なマネージャーを
大量に育成してくるということにおいては
非常に大きな貢献をしたわけです
ただ 今突きつけられているのは
申し上げたように
不足しているのは
マネージャーではなくてリーダーだと
成功している企業
大きくなっている企業には
大量のマネージャーがいます
だけど わずかなリーダーしかいない
いかにリーダーを育成するかということが
求められているということです
ただ リーダーというのは
当然個人です
ですから 最後は
個人の問題ということです
リーダー あるいはリーダーシップ
こうしたものの資質であるとか
要件というのは
色々ともう書かれていると思います
「ビジョナリーである」
「コミュニケーションのスキルが高い」
「カリスマ性がある」
色々あると思います
その中で もし
ひとつ最も大事なリーダーの資質は
という風に問われれば
これは決断をする力だと思います
決断というのは文字通り
「決」めて「断」つ
こういう能力が リーダーに
求められるんだと思います
ところが 変革をするということは
当然リスクを伴うわけです
今うまくいっている事業を破壊する
ということになるかもしれない
そういう意味においては
決めて断つために
必要なものは何かというと
最後にみなさんにメッセージとして
申し上げたいのは「カレッジ」
勇気だということです
みなさんの健闘を祈ります
（拍手）